his first yacht rock residency is
dropping anchor at the rio the
docksiders have their first show tonight
and jc fernandez is live inside the rio
with a preview how you doing jc
[Music]
ziggler here this is kevin good to see
you buddy ac how are you you got the
memo look at how you came dressed we're
matching you're in the band well later
on i'm going to transform into an
unofficial member of the i love it i
love transformation so what is not
familiar what is yacht rock yacht rock
is loosely defined as soft rockets of
the 70s and 80s so we play the stuff
that you know when i was younger i
listened to in the dance chair yeah but
that's great music it's rich the lyrics
mean something it's deep it's the
masterful productions the performances
are second and this was before they had
the technology that just about anybody
could be a singer you had to be able to
sing you had to be able to bring it and
that's what we're going to be doing here
five nights a week at the duomo at the
rio and you can tonight is opening night
people can still come down it's a big
media event but anything can come down
and watch the show truly come down come
have some phone with us the the show
starts at 6 pm how did you decide to put
together a yacht rock band because this
is brilliant this is the first ever
yacht rock residency in las vegas we had
the best of the best doing it how did
this concept come about you know it's
just a love of the music and some of the
band members uh share the same
sentiments and when we started toying
with the idea
it was new and it was fresh and we said
let's just throw it together and see
what we do and for the last four years
we've we've been very fortunate we've
had a lot of success traveling around
the country but we are really excited to
drop our proverbial anchor here in las
vegas and entertain at the entertainment
capital of the world and the entire band
is now las vegas residents they all
moved to town coming up like i said i'm
going to transform into an unofficial
member of the band and we're going to do
yacht rock name that tune sounds great
i'll teach you some moves sounds good
all right thank you kevin i'll send back
to you guys in the studio oh we need
more than an hour if he's going to teach
jc some moves we're going to check back
in with you jc later on in the show